Republicans trying to seize the momentum
after slugging it out at another
contentious debate the Big Talk of the
night was the blow up between Nikki
Haley and V ramaswami which devolved
into a series of personal insults I want
to be careful to avoid making the
mistakes from the neocon establishment
of the past do you want a leader from a
different generation who's going to put
this country first or do you want Dick
Cheney and 3-in heels case we've got two
of them on stage they're 5 in heels and
I don't wear them unless you can run in
them in the last debate she made fun of
me for actually joining Tik Tok while
her own daughter was actually using the
app for a long time so you might want to
take care of your family first leave my
of your adult daughter just
easy was it wasn't just the taunts a
candidat is digging into the issues
about the issues that Americans care
most about watch here everything
involving bionomics I'm going to rip it
up I'm going to throw it in the trash
can on day one I have a son who's in the
audience tonight who 30 years old if he
can't adjust to a fewe increase in
Social Security retirement age over the
next 40 years I got bigger problems with
him than his Social Security payments
level with the American people here
Ukraine is not a paragon of democracy so
to frame this as some kind of battle
between good versus evil don't buy it my
foreign policy is simple you cannot
negotiate with evil you have to destroy
it we'll put 25,000 more border patrol
and Ice agents on the ground and let
them do their job we will defund
Sanctuary CI of course once again the
GOP front runner was not there instead
Donald Trump held his own rally about 10
miles away and mocked his Republican
Rivals the thing and I was watching
these guys they're not watchable
standing in front of tens of thousands
of people right now and it's on
television that's a hell of a lot harder
to do than a
debate but we can't forget the biggest
headline of the night it was a short
moment you might have even missed it you
think the Democrats would actually hire
Greg Gutfeld to toast a democratic
debate they wouldn't do it I don't know
Greg your name was invoked you get 30
seconds to respond well you know what uh
I can't tell if that was a compliment or
an insult you know he says they wouldn't
do that but I you know what it to me it
would be a demotion because I'm here
saving the world and also they could not
handle me moderating a debate I would
outshine them all that was why the last
time Dana I said try Dana Perino I I
because I said they needed Dana's
lightness to balance out the
intellectual depth of
Univision anyway um Nikki's response
calling him scum was a little harsh it
revealed a personal animosity I don't
think they're going to share a ticket
but I thought my my my favorite part was
at the end where both used their
families as buffers right you know it
was like Hamas wasn't the only one using
human Shields they were like going like
nope I got my kid here I got my kid
there I thought that was interesting I
thought I thought VI though won the
night because he was the most memorable
and Unapologetic and his voice by far is
the strongest I mean it's it's you know
D santis is a good leader but he's not
good at this and it doesn't shine and
Tim Scott I couldn't remember a thing uh
but him going out VI going after the RNC
for their inexplicable
choices with the boss in the room that
takes some serious work rhymes with
talls uh and it's true because you know
biased Democrats asking questions that
usually guaranteed they'll be loaded
with antagonism means you have to unang
untangle the question before you can
actually talk about whether you're
qualified or not uh I think the the the
Tik Tock thing I think what VI he made a
good point that it's not about data
collection Republicans keep talking
about data collection it's about brain
collection mhm so you got to look closer
at home you got to look at the kids you
can't talk about Tik Tok if your kids
are on it and Tik Tok is that rare
phenomenon that can get healthy kids to
mutilate themselves under the delusion
of gender affirmation uh it's warping
young minds so I don't think you can
rail against Tik Tok unless you say I
don't want my kids on there because it's
not it isn't about data collection it's
about what what's happening to kids um
there were no complaints really though
about the questions that I saw
well I have a confession I didn't watch
the entire debate I was changing diapers
y i job you at the White
House very good Greg that's why you
should have co-hosted that I but what I
did my impression was that VI dominated
and whatever it is about v he's able to
capitalize on the format because he's
incredibly charismatic incredibly
articulate and he creates these
breakthrough moments that everybody
talks about now is he the most Charming
person on the stage he probably lacks a
little charm and that's his deficiency
but he's gotten into this sweet spot of
populism where you are thrashing around
at the powers that be you're a little
isolationist and you don't sound like a
politician and V doesn't sound like a
politician and he's connecting
emotionally to people out there Nikki
Haley smart Earnest liked what you said
about
abortion
sometimes she doesn't really translate
with the Grassroots if you know what I
mean and the attack against D santis for
not drilling in the Everglades I mean I
don't know anybody would drill in the
Everglades or offshore and the beautiful
beaches off there D santis I agree Greg
I I looked online after the debate
trying to find moments what happened
with D santis I couldn't find anything
and he's and then I had to look and I
looked at what he said sounds good yeah
yeah makes the right points but there's
no there's no Sizzle with DeSantis and I
just don't think this race changes at
all after that J Janine what did you
think well it's interesting I think that
the uh Nikki haly calling bake scum was
over the top and I ran for office five
times I get it when they come after your
family believe me I get it um but I
think Greg and I I agree with you on
that I think that her reaction was more
about V saying uh not just that you're
di chain and 3-inch heels but that she's
on the board of Ron and she's on the
board of LED and she's a neocon and she
wants to go in and bomb everybody and I
thought that that's what got under her
skin uh for her to call him scum I I
thought just saying daughter yeah I um
but but I think that V I think that V is
very much as Jesse said uh he's a
populist he said a lot of things that
people wanted to hear the biggest uh um
Applause in the audience and the crowd
went crazy when VI went after um is is
it Kristen Welker uh and he said you
know uh you basically did a Russia
collusion hoax for four years and you're
up here you know moderating this debate
and the audience went nuts so in my
nonscientific and certainly random
Twitter poll of 20,000 people today and
I want to thank you for answering uh 79%
of those people thought that vake won um
I think that I I think that Nikki on
abortion and that whole issue she is so
well uh she's thought it out so well and
I think that um she is really on top of
her game there um I think that in the
end uh Des s
he can do the job but he's not he can't
get any excitement I mean you just kind
of look at him and go oh it's him again
you know he have his cowboy boots on
again you know there's really nothing to
say all right Jessica well as the Target
demographic for the debate last night
I'm pleased to share my opinions on
great um just kidding not voting the GOP
Primary but um I did think that bake
went too far I thought it was about the
daughter that she got so upset I mean
she's had she's run for office for a
very long time she knows what it's like
to be personally attacked that was a
visceral mom move that didn't feel like
a racon thing to me though of course she
doesn't like being called neocon
establishment and all of that but
frankly I think it's benefiting her and
she should lean into it as much as
possible because there are two lanes
there's the populace Lane and there's
the establishment Lane and Donald Trump
owns the populace Lane until Donald
Trump is out of this race for whatever
reason and I don't expect that he will
be certainly listening to how he's
talking about it that leaves one other
spot and DeSantis Chris Christie and
Nikki Haley and Tim Scott who I
think blew up his whole I mean it's been
a slow roll blow up and then last night
when he looked at the results from the
night before and said we need a 15we
national
ban it's over like that is the most
inelegant thing that you can say after
people in Ohio told you conservatives
Ohio told you that they don't want to
talk about abortion banss but Nikki
Haley for me presented as the most
feasible candidate that could win a
general election if it's Nikki Haley
versus Joe Biden I saw this popping up
in liberals Twitter feeds last night
that that's someone who they could it's
not their choice but they could go to
bed on Election night and not worry
about what the next four years is going
to look like if it's ncky Haley
um the VES line about Rona McDonald
McDaniel sorry um and what's going on
with the GOP I thought was really
meaningful that he had considered the
election results and that's something if
Republicans want to change this culture
of losing that I think is important to
do um I continue to like Chris Christie
I think the way that he talked about the
pro-life movement also including people
who are suffering from addiction was
really meaningful and I don't know why
that doesn't happen more often that you
consider everybody it's not just about
preserving life in the womb but also
taking care of people who are on the
outside
and I just want to note you know Donald
Trump was having his rally and he was
throwing out lines like Kim Jong-un rule
rules 1.4 billion people um and they
have no doubt who the boss is and they
want me to say that he's not an
intelligent man that's the perfect ju
toos for Nikki Haley right to talk about
the fact that we don't praise dictators
like that we don't talk about other
leaders you just pay
them okay hi everyone I'm Brian killme I
want you do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now